[Musik]
ich habe den nachbarn umgebracht wird
sicherlich gesagt gar nicht so besonders
anfällig zu sein einer meiner hand
blutet jetzt und das ist das einzige was
mich stört an gott das blut aufgewachsen
ein
nein das war es ganz gewiss nicht denn
das grauen ging weiter
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
[Musik]
mein name ist es kalt und ich begrüße
euch zu einer weiteren folge von tatort
deutschland an dieser stelle möchte ich
euch erneut den hinweis geben dass
vieles was in den nächsten minuten in
worte gefasst wird schwer erträgliche
verstörende bilder im kopf erzeugen kann
der herr nickel viele von euch können
sich vielleicht noch an die episode 2
von tatort deutschland erinnern in der
wir diesen fall aus dem jahr 2017
ergründet haben es ging dort um eines
der grausamsten verbrechen der jüngeren
deutschen kriminalgeschichte bild
chefreporter frank schneider spürt noch
heute fünf jahre später das gefühl von
damals als der schrecken seinen lauf
nahm und obwohl der fall mit einem
schuldspruch und einer langen haftstrafe
zu ende ging bleiben bis heute viele
fragen wie kann ein junger mensch die
masse lese so kaltblütig und grausam
sein was ging während der taten wirklich
in ihm vor in dieser doppel folge von
tatort deutschland wird frank schneider
den fall nochmals betrachten und am ende
den mörder treffen
zurück zum anfang märz 2017 frank
schneider an noch nicht im geringsten
was auf ihn zukommt er mir noch genau
erinnern dass ich ganz früh morgens
einen anruf bekam von einem fotografen
und von einem kameramann die nachts
unterwegs gewesen sind und die damals
erzählten dass es eben in herne zu einem
mord an einem kind gekommen ist was ich
mir damals natürlich überhaupt nicht
habe vorstellen können dass einer der
spektakulärsten fälle in meinem report
erleben werden würde insbesondere weil
der täter hinterher mit seinen taten im
internet angegeben hat er hat fotos
kompost er hat neue tagen angekündigt es
gab hinterher eine fahnung bundesweit
wohl wirklich gefühlt jeder bundesbürger
wusste dass es dieser killer erst auf
der flucht er ist gefährlich er sucht
sich neue opfer und ganz deutschland
gefühlt hat nach ihnen gefahndet nach
ihnen gesucht wenn man selber vater ist
berührt einen so was natürlich viel viel
stärker weil man natürlich immer darüber
nachdenkt was wäre wenn es da was machst
du da zerstört hat ich glaube in das ist
es häufig diese gedanken lassen den bild
reporter frank schneider bis heute nicht
los der journalist mit dem grauen
dreitagebart und in kurz gebastelten
haaren wird in dieser folge den blutigen
spuren und der kranken psyche eines
brutalen täters folgen
diese spuren führen ihn zu den opfern
und zu einer außergewöhnlichen begegnung
mit der trivialität des bösen es war ein
beklemmendes komisches gefühl sei total
interessant zu sehen wie er mit den
taten umgeht oder teilweise eben nicht
mit diesen taten um mit seiner schuld
umgeht und es war ein tag der in meiner
zeit als journalist auch ein besonderer
bleiben wird lassen sie uns gemeinsam
zurückblicken in den abendstunden des 6
märz 2017 wird ein neunjähriger junge
aus herne ermordet und wenige stunden
später am siebten märz ein 22 jähriger
mann erstochen in seiner brennenden
wohnung aufgefunden
die polizei in nrw seit gestern abend
einen mutmaßlichen kindermörder er ist
19 jahre alt
der noch fast kindlich wirkende täter
mit dicker brille und schmaler nase
brüstet sich im internet mit seinen
taten er postet bilder seine verbrechen
und veröffentlicht höhnische
menschenverachtende sprachnachrichten
vielleicht wirklich noch ein nachbar
über noch das gleiche da hab ich jetzt
zwei morde offen heißt frank schneider
ist noch heute von den tondokumenten
bestürzt die geschichte war am anfang
der mord an einem kind was schon
schrecklich genug aber dann entwickelte
sich immer mehr dass dieser täter im
internet offenbar mit seinen taten an
gibt aber neue taten ankünden
zu vergewaltigen die ganze region um
herne ist in aufruhr ja fast nahe einer
panik was wird der täter als nächstes
tun
bild berichtet von anfang an aus nrw
chefreporter frank schneider zieht in
diesen stunden die ersten informationen
in der redaktion zusammen und macht sich
dann sofort selbst auf den weg auf wege
der heute fünf jahre später erneut
gefährt
die sonne scheint während der reporter
senden wagen durch die alleen rund um
herrn de lenkt dann sind ja auch hier es
gibt hier viele grün wird keine wälder
kleine park und die polizei hatte halt
immer die sorge dass er sich noch
weitere opfer sucht und dass er sich
hier irgendwo versteckt hält und damit
ich in der einen oder zwei turniertagen
herrn hin und her gefahren da kann man
sich ungefähr vorstellen mich
kompliziert ist auch für die polizei war
das war es die sicherheitskräfte boten
alles auf was zum schnellen ergreifen
des flüchtigen täters führen würde hier
sind wir im bereich von herne wo damals
die polizei überall gesucht hat es waren
schwer bewaffnete hundertschaften
unterwegs suchhunde und schrauber und
immer wieder hat die polizei hinweise
bekomme aus der bevölkerung und trotzdem
liegt der mörder vorerst verschwunden
wo ist master messe die polizei ein
halbes jahr zeit gestern abend einen
mutmaßlichen kindermörder was ein hesse
ist seit 24 stunden auf der flucht
nachdem er einen 9 jährigen nachbarin
umgebracht haben sollen reporter frank
schneider berichtet damals sofort live
bei bild tv mann ist so extrem
gefährlich wir wissen überhaupt nicht
was er vorhat er hat absolut nichts mehr
zu verlieren es kann sein dass er
möglicherweise neue opfer sucht die
polizei ist in absoluter
alarmbereitschaft
während die polizei fieberhaft fahndete
stürzt für jeanette f mutter des
neunjährigen schäden im beschaulichen
wanne eickel die ganze welt in sich
zusammen kurz nach der tat erzählt sie
den bild reportern was am 6 märz 2017
geschah
grund dessen hatte ich den dann auch
früh nahm es dann auch nicht mit genug
zum einkauf er sagt er ist okay dann
warte ich auf die ich nach hause komme
oder nicht mehr da aber dahinter gehört
dass der nachbar denn hier angestellt
hätte machte gefragt hatte ob er rüber
kommen können die leiter festhalten und
leiter aufstellen
solar haus immer hallo hallo gerufen
aber da hat sich nichts gehört ja nett
wirkt innen interviews völlig erschöpft
vielleicht hat sie schon dass sie nun am
anfang eines endlosen materi ums steht
sie weiß dass dieser mord ihr weiteres
leben für immer überschattet eine
knallrote gefärbte haarsträhne luke
damals unter einer schwarzen strickmütze
hervor sie trägt piercing schmuck und
bunte tuch jeanette f berichtet was sie
vor fünf jahren spürte irgendetwas
stimmt nicht sie ging daraufhin zu den
nachbarn bei denen licht brennt und bei
denen jeden angeblich eine leiter halten
sollte zur gleichen zeit begibt sich der
damalige lebenspartner von jeanette
pascal f auf die suche nach schäden in
den gärten hinter den reihenhäusern auf
den terrassen und in den keller zugängen
und er entdeckt gleich nebenan
schreckliches
wir haben uns gesucht haben gesehen dass
das rauskommt der leuchte war in europa
bauen immer geklopft und geklingelt und
bin dann meinen wir uns ausruhen und
dann hier vorne die terrassentüren rein
nach der
was pascal erfindet ist die mit
unzähligen messerstichen übersät leiche
von schäden nun ist es gewissheit der
junge ist nicht nur mal eben
verschwunden nein er wird nie wieder
kommen
zurück im jahr 2022 frank schneide ist
erneut im fall marcel risse unterwegs im
auto auf dem weg zum ehemaligen tatort
wirkt der bild chefreporter sehr
nachdenklich was treibt ihn an ich
erhoffe mir zu sehen dass die familien
ist doch geschafft haben mit dieser
schrecklichen tat zu leben was anderes
ist ja nicht sein irgendwie weiter zu
machen ich habe immer den satz im kopf
es gibt nur eine entscheidung als opfer
angehört du gehst unter oder du
schwimmst und ich hoffe dass dies
geschafft haben zu schwimmen dass sie es
geschafft haben diese taten insofern zu
verarbeiten dass die unterstützung haben
dass sie hilfe haben das wird sicher
nicht an der spannendsten fragen seien
in diesem fall um jetzt nach fast fünf
jahren zu erfahren wie es weitergegangen
der journalist stellt seinen wagen in
eine kleine nebenstraße ab kaum etwas
hat sich seit 2000 17 verändert die
sonne scheint und nur ein paar singvögel
durchbrechen die mittägliche ruhe
ich bin jetzt hier in einem kleinen
beschaulichen wohngebiet in herne man
sieht beschauliche reihenhäuser hier
sind kleine mehrfamilienhäuser
doch hier geschah damals diese grausame
schreckliche tat denn hier vorne in
diesen reihenendhaus auf der linken
seite wurde damals jane im keller
ermordet hinter dieser tür von
hausnummer 30 c
dort wurde jake mit 52 messerstichen
getötet der reporter atmet tief durch
ich bin seit 28 jahren journalist unser
20 jahren chefreporter bei bild ich war
immer schon polizeireporter war bei
vielen terroranschlägen schweren
verbrechen und auch bei amokläufen aber
ein fall der mich nie losgelassen hat
weil er so sinnlos ist der fall des
herrn killers der zwei menschen getötet
hat und daraus entwickelte sich einer
der spektakulärsten fahndungen und
kriminalfälle überhaupt die ich je
erlebt habe dann blickt er um die ecke
des letzten hauses am ende der straße
ein idylle mit seinen unzähligen grünen
vorgärten den biotonnen vom eingang und
den fahrrädern und autos in den
auffahrten durch diesen garten liefen
damals der stiefvater von jane und sein
großer bruder sie suchten jeden er
wusste es im nachbarhaus das war hell
erleuchtet doch es öffnete niemand
sofort blitzen schreckliche bilder in
frank schneiders kopf auf und
erinnerungen an die ersten gespräche mit
james familie
[Musik]
bin nach oben gerannt und dann kann man
so schon in gegen tabus und war am
schreien der schäden wichtig immer auf
dem boden alles ist voller blut ich
glaube das tut
dann ist auch zusammen
[Musik]
schon gesagt
das wird man niemals vergessen können
wird irgendwann mal lernen können und
damit ins
visier bis jetzt schlafe ich ein stück
[Musik]
chefreporter frank schneider war hat
einen moment vor dem eingang des
reihenhauses würde nicht jeder der so
einen grausamen einschnitt in seinem
leben erleiden musste möglichst weit weg
vom ort des geschehens flüchten jedes
familie entschloss sich zu bleiben
direkt daneben wohnt bis heute die
mutter mit dem bruder von jane der
journalist wird wie ein freund der
familie empfangen das haus ist modern
und hell eingerichtet gegens mutter ist
etwas älter geworden und die wachen
augen blitzen heute hinter einer brille
sie wirkt der noch jung die haare noch
immer feuerrot und viel länger als
damals sie zum pferdeschwanz gebunden
neue tätowierungen schmücken jeanette
sichtbare haut an armen händen und als
die mutter dreier kinder wird
selbstbewusst und gleichzeitig
angespannt du wirst hier wurden
geblieben da wo es alles passiert ist im
nachbarhaus war das eine bewusste
entscheidung und wie gehst du damit um
das ist vielleicht für dich sogar
wichtig dass du mir geblieben ist
hat am anfang als weggefahren sind das
gibt nämlich das zurück das
[Musik]
wollte ich auch hier wohnen bleiben und
ich weiß definitiv die beste
entscheidung ist wichtig entscheidung
getroffen habe jetzt nicht in diesen
keller zu denen die das noch mit dem
kopf sitzen da ist ja auch beim nachbarn
im keller war und das war noch nicht was
sein sohn
glaube ich würde ich jetzt nicht hier
sitzen wie geht es den menschen die
gegen gefunden haben da es gibt genauso
moment bei mir auch
so halt depressionen kommen und
wo es halt schwierig ist somit der
psyche klarzukommen da
das jetzt wenn ich immer aber
ein bisschen besser im griff
reden ist wichtig und vielleicht umso
wichtiger mit einem gewissen zeitlichen
abstand der chefreporter erzählt james
mutter von seinem plan den fall und den
täter noch einmal genauer zu betrachten
sie begrüßt das vorhaben grundsätzlich
stellt aber in bezug auf den
verurteilten mörder schlicht fest
ich habe jetzt gar mit james mutter
gesprochen und muss sagen ich bin immer
noch beeindruckt von der frau wie stark
sie ist wie sie versucht mit der
situation umzugehen wie sie immer noch
für ihre anderen kinder da ist und wie
sie aber auch ehrlich gesagt hat die
situation in ihrem leben gab wo sie
dachte es geht einfach nicht weiter man
merkt ihr an obwohl sie so stark ist wie
es immer noch situationen gibt darüber
kann sie kaum sprechen dann versagt
jedoch die stimme es kommt training ihre
augen und ich kann es nur zu gut
nachvollziehen ich bin selber vater und
wenn ich mir vorstelle dass dieser frau
widerfahren jetzt kann ich nur sagen in
beeindruckt von ihrer stärke und dieses
geschafft hat trotzdem weiter zu gehen
frank schneider macht einen kleinen
umweg über die a43 obwohl er eigentlich
nur direkt hinein nach buchung möchte er
gibt kräftig gas und ordnet sich in den
verkehr ein der umweg hilft der
journalist kann bei monotonen autofahren
die gedankengut fokussieren wer war
dieser masse lese
2017 gerade einmal 19 jahre alt die
haben alle gesagt für uns war ein
harmloser idiotischer spinner der sich
wichtigen daten vielleicht war das sogar
daraus würde dass man seriös an beweisen
wollte ich bin gefährlich ich bin nicht
der berliner lacht jetzt zeige ich euch
mal was nicht alles machen da wirklich
keine gefühle hat er keine reue um
dieser frage noch mal nachzugehen trifft
frank schneider einen alten bekannten
wie ist ein junger mensch in der lage so
was zu tun
ich bin jetzt hier vor dem
polizeipräsidium in bochum habe jetzt
einen termin mit hauptkommissar volker
schütte er war damals pressesprecher hat
damals die fahndung mit betreut nach
marcel risse und er kam mir nochmal
erzählen wie der stand der ermittlungen
damals war und wie er damals die
situation diese großfahndung erlebt hat
das backsteingebäude mit den frisch
gestrichenen weißen fensterrahmen hat
der reporter in seiner langen karriere
schon unzählige male betreten er würde
sich quasi mit verbundenen augen
zurechtfinden aber hauptkommissar volker
schütte empfängt den journalisten im
foyer und begleitet ihn durch das
treppenhaus
warum war dieses verbrechen für sie so
einschneidend ja es war diese brutalität
die man sich nicht nur vorstellen konnte
man konnte sich das ja auch anschauen im
internet er wir haben die bilder er dann
auch gesehen die im internet
veröffentlicht worden sind mehr was auch
nicht bewusst dass man die so schnell
ins internet hochgeladen hat wir sind
auch in den ersten stunden vom darknet
ausgegangen und erst später an dem tag
mussten der dann das ist diese plattform
ist wo wir dann natürlich auch gestöbert
haben und einfach entsetzt waren was für
widerlichkeit dort gesehen
nicht nur fotos gepostet er hat auch
audio botschaft also sprache nachrichten
verschickt in denen er unglaublich
eiskalt über die taten gesprochen hat
sich auch lustig gemacht hat über die
tage auf einem tablett schauen sich die
beiden männer die chartverläufe der
tatnacht an ich habe konnte sich
[Musik]
der polizist scrollt durch die datenbank
auch da war ja dann irgendwann der satz
ist ich mache ich muss was knast weil
ich es machen sehr schnell kam mir der
gedanke das ist alles glaubwürdig
[Musik]
das tablet wird kurz zur seite gelegt
nachdenklich 40 der fahne hauptkommissar
über das kind sind hier offen kinder
ermordet worden das hat auch schon
schlimmer kapitaldelikte gegeben auch
schon wirklich deutschlandweit bekannte
aber hier was ein kleiner junge und ted
der täter war flüchtig konnte die sache
erst bedingt einschätzen wir haben dann
aber gemerkt was für ein drive diese
geschichte genommen hat auch bei den
medien es kam sehr schnell rüber hier
ist ein ganz ganz gefährlicher mensch
unterwegs und dann fängt auch hier die
sorgen im präsidium was es gibt es
möglicherweise weitere teile der bild
chefreporter nicht langsam und lehnt
sich zurück diese zeit damals war für
uns auch wirklich schon sehr
herausfordernd sehr anstrengend auch
weil es ja keine ruhepausen gab immer
wieder kam auch neue nachrichten von dem
täter und wusste ja wie gesagt immer
nicht gibt es bereits weitere opfer
wiesen opfer gibt es noch was kommt als
nächstes von täter auf dem tablet wird
ein weiterer clip abgespielt
diese sprachnachrichten und fotos
konnten sich damals alle im netz anhören
und ansehen
unsicherheit macht sich daraufhin in der
ganzen region um herne breit vielleicht
hat der killer ja schusswaffen
vielleicht ist er ein amokläufer ein
terrorist die straßen waren menschenleer
den menschen angst die seien auch
tagsüber fast leeren also wirklich schon
schon ganz beängstigende szenen die sich
am gespielt haben weil ja auch wirklich
in keiner wusste was macht er als
nächstes denn er gab mir immer mehr oder
weniger damit an dass er noch ist es
weitere opfer suchen und betonte auch
dass in gar nichts ausmachen würde
menschen zu töten aber das jetzt gemacht
und das war ja ganz leicht etwas mache
eben nicht deshalb war die angst
natürlich bei den menschen die sorge
nachdem marcel hieße den neunjährigen
jaden auf bestialische weise ermordet
hat kann sich der täter nicht
entscheiden was er als nächstes tun soll
er dann hat er einen fußmarsch hingelegt
werden hubschrauber fliegen lassen hunde
sind eingesetzt worden leider haben wir
masse lässt nicht mehr erwischt er
brauchte nur diese fünf bis sechs
kilometer sind zu einem jahr freund will
ich gar nicht mal sagen zu einem
bekannten den er wohl aus kollege
schulzeiten kannte in christopher und
hat ihm dann wohl die geschichte erzählt
törmer meine eltern sind umgezogen ich
komme da alles noch nicht so klar kann
ich möglicherweise mal für zwei drei
tage bei ihr übernachten dann hat man
zusammen karten gespielt man hat
zusammen filme geguckt und erzählt
zusammen gegen 2 uhr schlafen gelegt es
sollte die letzte nacht im leben des 22
jährigen christopher wie sein der
sympathische lockenkopf kann nicht ahnen
zu welchem wahnsinn sein gast fähig ist
ja und jeden mann ist wahrscheinlich
dann dieser christopher morgens wach
geworden und wie junge menschen das
machen man schaut mal kurz ins netz und
dann sieht er das foto
seines kumpels masse lässt der direkt
neben ihm noch schläft ja back tim wohl
und ja ich glaube das war das
todesurteil
der junge mann ist sicherlich grausam
gequält worden also wieder eine
widerwärtige tag hier auch hier passiert
ist
der reporter setzt sich wieder ins auto
und fährt zurück nach herne diesmal
mitten in die stadt mit ihren eng
stehenden gründerzeithäusern
hier oben im ersten stock hat er sich
damals bei seinem kumpel christopher
versteckt und hat sich dort zwei tage
verborgen gehalten die anwohner hier in
der ganzen straße keiner wusste dass er
sich hier versteckt hält von schneider
steigt die alten knaben holzstufen in
dem hausflur nach oben es ist düster und
muffig das fahle gelbe licht lässt alles
schäbig wird ich gehe jetzt noch mal zu
diesem zweiten tatort und möchte mit den
anwohnern noch mal sprechen die damals
selber lebensgefahr waren hier oben ist
wasserdicht und damals auch hoch gehören
in den abend die ersten tat hier vorne
ist die wohnungstür von
der wohnmodell damals christopher wohnte
als der journalist die treppe wieder
hinunter geht erinnerte sich damals mit
einer nachbarin gesprochen zu haben sie
kannte christopher sie kannte seine
mutter sie kennt die ganzen hintergründe
auch des falls schneider versucht es
erneut und klingelt an einer der türen
ein kurzes gespräch auf dem
treppenabsatz ergibt sich die ältere
frau erinnert sich noch an den tag der
für sie ganz normal begann haben sie
denn damals irgendwas dadurch das neue
zufällig mitbekommen vielleicht
geräuschen
zur arbeit gegangen wie immer um 8 und
da habe ich da oben was ziemlich lauten
streit und da wollte ich erst auf gehen
aber ich hatte es auch als ich am morgen
habe ich gedacht na ja jungen wir
streiten sich ja mal neben anderen aber
der hat ihnen vorgeführt dabei wusste
nicht woher sie kommen was war der
christoph verwenden sie haben ja lange
mit ihm hier gelebt von menschen typ wie
würden sie ihn beschreiben ganz lieber
er war zudem zu leben
das vielleicht auch der grund gewesen
warum er den reingelassen
[Musik]
müssen sehen heute immer noch wieder
daran denken an das was damals
[Musik]
oder so ich ihm ein pfefferspray mit
weil ich bin mir jetzt ganz sicher die
leute waren alle zu hause her und der
junge hat um hilfe geschrien und es hat
ihnen hier im haus keiner gehört dieser
lesung stimme dann können dass jemand um
sein leben um hilfe schreit keiner hat
[Musik]
aber noch einmal zurück zum kommissariat
in bochum und zu volker schütte der den
weiteren verlauf vom wüten des marcel
hesse skizziert
gegeben in einem wohnhaus als die
feuerwehr den brand gelöscht hat oder
beim löschen sind da leichen entdeckt
wurden die polizei schwerbewaffnete
hundertschaften sek alle haben ihn
besucht marcel wurde quer durch die
republik mehr oder weniger verfolgt und
er versteckt ist die ganze zeit in
dieser wohnung und am ende war es dann
so
vielleicht ist sein hass auf die
menschheit nach der gewaltorgie
verraucht befriedigt durch zwei morde an
unschuldigen oder ist der herner keller
einfach nur auf anerkennung aus
jedenfalls nutzt der zweifache mörder
die pc des toten christopher um sich
erneut mit seinen taten im netz zu
brüsten volker schütte und der reporter
scrollen durch die letzten post des
mörders man fragt sich auch wie ist ein
junger mensch in der lage so was zu tun
wie ist man in der lage direkt danach
sich wieder an einen rechner zu setzen
fotos einzustellen und durchaus
geschliffene leute zu schreiben auf
einem foto kann ich mich noch erinnern
das war nicht so unglaublich
unvorstellbar dass ein stück pizza da
lag aber was er offenbar auf oder neben
der gleiche pizza gegessen hat jetzt da
unvorstellbar fragt es um etwas geht in
so einem menschen vor der mörder legt
dilettantisch einen brand vielleicht um
seine spuren zu verwischen
vielleicht einfach aus langeweile
dann verlässt er die wohnung seines
opfers christopher w
[Musik]
kommen zu einem daily spezial heute
abend endlich sie haben ihn der
mutmaßliche kinder killer marcel hesse
hat sich heute abend in einem
schnellimbiss der polizei gestellt
wir waren heilfroh wirklich alle
heilfroh als dann an diesem
donnerstagabend der erlösende anruf kann
wir haben ihn und ich glaube das ganze
präsidium nicht nur das präsidium dem
buchen sondern auch dortmund und auch
die bevölkerung war heilfroh diesen
menschen fest auch diesen ort besucht
chefredakteur frank schneider fünf jahre
nach den morden nochmal den imbiss
thessaloniki griechische spezialitäten
gibt es noch immer
nur 200 meter entfernt vom letzten
tatort ging marcel risse an dem abend
genau dieses stück hier auf dem gehweg
zu diesem imbiss hier vorne und stellte
sich dort er sagte damals zudem wird ich
bin der gesuchte marcel rufen sie die
polizei der täter ist gefasst die
blutige reise des muscle asse ist zu
ende die verarbeitung seiner unfassbaren
taten beginnt nun aber erst wie hat dass
die menschen mitgenommen herne diese
taten auch ihre kollegen gab es da auch
nach betreuung oder musste die sogar
sein hauptkommissar volker schütte denkt
einen moment nach geht in sich wir haben
da einen termin in einer schule wo
seelsorger sich um die kinder gekümmert
haben die mit dem jaden zusammen in die
schule gegangen sind das war für mich
eine veranstaltung ich muss sagen da war
gänsehaut feeling was für eine angst
dann noch da war auch kollegen von uns
mussten natürlich betreut wenn das sind
bilder für junge polizisten waren mit am
tatort unsere spurensicherung die haben
das natürlich sagt geht es mal ganz
platt mit voller breite seite sehen
müssen diese bilder die auch die
angehörigen von reden oder die helfer
gesehen haben wie dieser kleine junge
der nach und leider haben es auch
millionen menschen wahrscheinlich sich
auch im internet angeguckt einfach
widerlich antrag es hat in dem fall eben
auch nur verlierer gegeben die ehe der
eltern von jaden ist daran zerbrochen
die mutter von christopher den zweite
opfer ist mehr oder weniger auch an
kummer danach gestorben der leiter der
mordkommission die nicht viele filialen
kennen der viel gesehen hat er hart
gesotten war dieser fall hat den auch so
nachhaltig betroffen gemacht wurde dass
zum beispiel der auch hinterher seinen
job innerhalb der polizei hingeworfen
hat etwas anderes gemacht oder gesagt
hat ich kann das nicht mehr ich will das
nicht mehr
es gab nicht nur die beiden getöteten
menschen die zu opfern des verbrechens
wurden auch die familie james wird sich
kaum von dieser tat an ihrem sohn bruder
enkel erholen und auch die familie des
täters wird zum opfer der tat er
vernetzt zu der wohnung
der mutter des täters marcel hesse wir
haben damals kurz nach der tat versucht
kontakt zu der mutter aufzunehmen wir
haben sie dann auch erreicht und nach
langen vorgesprächen hat sich auch
bereit erklärt und erkennbar vor der
kamera mit uns zu sprechen das heißt mit
dem rücken zur kamera weil sie einfach
große scham empfand großen schmerz
natürlich auch
in der küche für michaela l sitzt der
reporter damals der mutter des herner
killers gegenüber nie war der tag an dem
sozusagen
nachhaltig verändert hat
ich werde auch da übernachten ich habe
mir das natürlich geglaubt dass die
nachbarin mich anrief die jenny sagte
sie du bei dir im haus brennt noch licht
weil ich kann nicht sein dies auch sagte
sie da brennt licht und dann war da der
leiter geholt als ich das hörte dachte
ich zuerst der wird ja wohl nicht
besucht haben die leute von der decke ab
zu kriegen und dachte an einen unfall
und ich hätte niemals gedacht dass sowas
fähig wäre absolut nicht und ich weiß
wie das sein muss als mutter
soweit die aktuelle bestandsaufnahme
reporter frank schneider fragt sich aber
wie der täter nach fünf jahren
strafvollzug über seine mode denkt er
will den mörder treffen lassen hiess
einen brief geschrieben ins gefängnis er
hat auch relativ prompt darauf reagiert
und mir geantwortet und
jetzt ist aus dem briefverkehr
entstanden dass wir uns treffen werden
dass wir gemeinsam in der jva uns mal
unterhalten können persönlich was marcel
hieße ihm im vorfeld auf diesen brief
antwortet und was der bild reporter
frank schneider im gefängnis über die
gedankenwelt des mörders erfährt das
hört ihr in der nächsten folge von
tatort deutschland bis dahin erste kino
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone terbrack
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
lutz neumann
redaktion bild frank schneider und
stefan netze 8